The funny thing about growing up is like,
even as you age, you don't feel like it. So
even though I'm about to be 42,
when I see like a 20 something year old girl,
I'm like, hey girlie.
Like in my head we're the same
and we're not,
but in my heart we're the same.
And I will never stop fighting for you.
And there is something kind of cool about becoming an older woman
and seeing how you do get dismissed by society
and you do slowly become less and less relevant.
You know, all the varying factors.
But there's like a freedom and a power in that.
Like, oh,
I'm gonna fight extra loud.
I'll be one of those fucking crazy old ladies screaming and fighting.
I understand them now.
I remember when I was younger looking at them and being like,
what the fuck is wrong with that old lady with like purple hair?
And I'm so excited to be one of them.
But we are never gonna stop fighting.
We're never gonna shut up.
I don't care that I got mine.
I don't care that I made it this far.
I don't want my daughters and the younger girls
to not have those same opportunities.
My heart is broken for the women that have already lost their lives
because of
some of these decisions.
I
don't know,
I'm also scared and mad and angry. But
we're never gonna stop fighting.